people often say to me they're like what
is sway and i
now at this point only can answer
that sway is radical positive change
my name is lindsey rose medlock and i'm
the ceo of suey so shop
we are a production sewing shop and we
specialize in upcycling meaning we cut
up old
post-consumer product and turn it into
new
desirable products growing up
fashion was a true way to express myself
and i remember the first time i went to
a thrift store
it was the seventh grade and i walked in
and it hit me like this is the mother
lode this is like the mecca this is who
i am
like the textures the colors the history
the opportunities that i saw in that
thrift store as like a young
seventh grader has driven me for the
rest of my life
to take all of this old stuff that no
one wanted anymore and
turn it into new product
fashion is like one of the biggest
polluters on the planet
yet it's one of the most celebrated ways
of expressing yourself
so how did we get here you know as an
industry
the textiles that don't get thrown in
the trash are being like bailed up
some of those bales are being buried in
landfills or being shipped
into other countries where we're selling
it off by the pound
but the stuff that does keep sitting
and does keep staying we keep collecting
and saving and it really
has nowhere to go and that's where
remade can really step
in and so
what we're doing is we're basically like
take a
you know bale of old like flannel shirts
and cut them up and turn them into
entirely new products
we're able to cut up hundreds of
thousands of pounds of old textiles that
were deemed for landfills and that's
what makes us so powerful
[Music]
so sustainability is not just like a
word that's attached to a product it's
like a way of life i think that we all
really have to embrace
i mean the way it's going to work is if
everyone becomes the everyday hero
in their own community and speaking up
for
what they know is actually going to have
an effect on whether
we have a sustainable future so we have
a
store of post-consumer product a
beautiful sewing shop
and we're all kind of like busy little
bees running around
cutting up garbage and sewing it back
together for the world
it's cool and then when cobit hit
it changed everything actually quite
quickly
uh jumped to our feet and started
raising money to start
producing masks and give them away to
frontliners and community members and
people that were
immunocompromised and we've given away
over
75 000 masks to date and are still
giving away masks every week
sway is also now half store half food
bank
we recently started a food bank for
garment workers and
now each week we're feeding up to 250
garment worker families a week
i really urge people that are involved
in fashion if you're wearing clothes
then you should care about this
because these are the same people that
are sewing the clothes that you have on
your back every single day
because change is habitual right like
what we have to do
from a personal level is to make shifts
to
create the kind of change that the world
desperately needs
we're here to show the world that
you do have the opportunity to live
every day doing a little bit better than
the day before
change is here and we just have to keep
trying to get more people on board